security forces in russia have detained
over 4 000 anti-war protesters across
the country the figure is from an
independent protest monitor police
arrested people in several russian
cities including moscow and petersburg
they've warned that organizers and
participants in demonstrations will face
charges
authorities have imposed restrictions on
protests citing the covert 19 pandemic
and we're now joined by constantine
egert dw's russia affairs analyst who
joins us from vilnius how effective
could protesting be given the large
number of detentions we're seeing in
russia right now
good morning uh i think that
these protests are very significant
because they continue
uh for days running now at the same time
the numbers of protesters are fairly
small for
140 plus million countries uh so it is
still not a massive movement not even
something that could be compared to the
anti-putin protests of 2011-2012
but there is one significant thing i
think
and it is the geography rather than the
numbers of detain although they are big
and unless these people are going to get
probably this time much harsher
treatment than usual uh it is uh the
fact that um russia only has i think 18
or 19 of the top of my head uh cities
with
a million population or more
that's where the internet is that's
where information is better that's where
there are there is more education so
support
now the geography of the protest is
about 50 seconds
that means that even in russian province
there is
now a gradual recognition that things
are
going wrong that the government
essentially is lying to them and that is
significant because in a smaller place
the effect of a rally is much bigger
because well i mean i wouldn't say
everyone knows everyone but
the the information about this the
effect of it public effect is much more
significant but i think uh that probably
this is still not something that shakes
putin's foundation however okay so so
the information is getting through but
tell us about this uh russian state
polling agency that's pointed out that
vladimir putin's approval rating in
russia has risen to 70 percent what do
you make of of that number
the polls are unreliable in russia uh
many people lie to the pollsters because
there is after russia's 20th century
revolution civil war two world wars uh
gulag uh people tend to understand that
the authorities may be listening so
they frequently tell the uh uh the
posters what they think the government
would like to hear
secondly uh frankly speaking current
circumstances i wouldn't be surprised
that any polling company probably apart
from one all of them are this or that
way controlled by the government or feel
government pressure they will probably
be ready to give figures that reflect
what the government wants to hear i
wouldn't bet on reading these walls i'm
sure though
that those people that watch
state television for example uh are
definitely seeing a different picture
yeah and they're definitely
they definitely think that putin is
wrong
um on the military front the u.s and
poland have been discussing the delivery
of fighter jets to ukraine how likely
is that to happen i mean would it be a
sign of nato's direct involvement
well that's what putin says he said that
weapons deliveries uh
will be hostile acts and and actually
said also closing the skies the
introducing a no-fly zone uh will be
seen as an act of war uh but i think
that uh things are gradually moving in
this direction
ukraine has
quite a big number
of uh people who
can be fighter pilots including those
who recently retired
my understanding is that this may be on
the table very soon just as by the way
uh a refusal to buy russian oil by say
the united states i think that maybe the
energy
energy weapon the
energy super weapon
is probably next uh next on the agenda
yeah it'll be interesting to see these
developments uh fast moving constantine
ergot thank you very much for bringing
us your analysis
well large crowds also gathered across
europe and the us over the weekend to
protest against the russian invasion
demonstrators took to the streets of
barcelona in spain
in the swiss city of geneva a crowd
saying the ukrainian national anthem in
new york city thousands converged on
times square to show their support and
demand measures from nato
[Music]
here's a look at some other developments
in the conflict
several western countries including the
us and uk have called on interpol to
immediately suspend russia from the
network according to a tweet from the
british home secretary the country's
cite the threat to public safety posed
by russia's invasion of ukraine interpol
is a network of 194 countries which
facilitate the policing of international
crime
the u.n nuclear watchdog says it's
concerned about reports that
communications have been disrupted at
ukraine's largest nuclear power plant
russian soldiers took the sapporo chia
facility on friday after shelling it and
have reportedly turned off its internet
and telephone lines reliable
communications are critical to safety
the social media company tic toc is
suspending the posting of videos from
russia this comes after moscow passed a
law introducing jail terms of up to 15
years for publishing what it calls fake
news about the army tick tock says it
needs to keep its employees safe